these days it can be tough keeping track
of everything that's going on in the mcu
but maybe that's not such a bad thing
after all
it just means more to look forward to
here are the most exciting marvel
projects coming over the horizon
juan division is among the more
intriguing of marvel's disney plus
series
overseen by captain marvel and black
widow screenwriter jack shafer
the show features the reunion of you
guessed it
wanda maximoff and vision of course
everyone's favorite robot boyfriend was
looking just a tad bit dead the last
time he appeared
which begs the question just how is he
making his return
well it seems almost certain at this
point that wand division takes place at
least partly within an alternate reality
especially given that the series will
tie into the events of doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness
the first trailer for wanda vision seems
to confirm that the show will venture to
a number of different realities
each set in a different decade and based
around a different style of american
sitcom
the series will also bring back kat
dinnings as darcy lewis
as well as randall park as jimmy wu mcu
newcomer catherine hahn is taking on the
role of wanda envisions nosy neighbor
agnes
while tiana paris will be playing a
grown-up version of monica rambo who was
last seen as a child in captain marvel
thankfully it won't be a terribly long
wait to discover how
all of these seemingly disparate
characters will come together
one division was originally slated to
debut on disney plus sometime in the
spring of next year
but the release date has been moved up
to january 15th
the so-called sony universe of marvel
characters was born of sony pictures
deal with marvel studios which allowed
marvel to integrate
spider-man into the mcu in exchange sony
continues to produce the web head's mcu
set solo outings and also has free reign
to develop its own universe based on
ancillary spider-man characters
this universe's inaugural effort 2018's
venom
cleaned up at the box office while
satisfying fans of the character left
cold by the last time the character
appeared in a feature film
do you remember
do you remember what you did to me after
venom's unexpected success
sony was quick to fast-track another
spidey-related property
one that has been gestating since 2017.
this would be morbius
based on the living vampire and frequent
spider-man nemesis who first appeared in
the pages of marvel comics in 1971 the
flick will star jared leto as dr michael
morbius a brilliant biochemist whose
attempts to cure his own potentially
fatal blood disease with an experimental
treatment go predictably awry
transforming him into a super powered
vampire daniel espinoza directs from a
script by lost in space co-creators matt
sezama
and burke sharpless of course where the
morbius can match venom's runaway
success has yet to be seen
but we'll know for sure on march 19th
2021
marvel has been promising a standalone
movie for natasha ramanov for years
and now on may 7 2021 it's finally
happening
with black widow in which scarlett
johansson will reprise the role of the
super spy avenger for what will likely
be the last time
the prequel is set in the period between
captain america civil war and avengers
infinity war
but will likely also flash back to the
time before romanov's recruitment by
shield
according to director kate shortland the
movie will find romanov in a dark place
shortland says in this film we get to
understand her past
and put the pieces of herself together
and come out a whole person
much of the action will take place
overseas and yes it seems fans will
finally get to find out just what went
down in budapest
johansen's co-stars include florence
pugh and rachel vice who will appear as
operatives who have undergone the same
red room training that honed ramanov's
deadly skills
also starring as david harbor who will
portray alexei chostokoff
aka the red guardian russia's answer to
captain america
rounding out the cast will be ot feck
bentley as marcus
an underworld fixer and ray winston
whose role is currently undisclosed
the debut for the mcu's first asian hero
shang chi was teased in late 2018
but until the full title was revealed in
july 2019
the particularly exciting involvement of
the movie's iconic villain
had only been rumored yes on july 9
2021 shang chi and the legend of the ten
rings will see the master of kung fu
face off against the mandarin the
classic iron man villain who notoriously
didn't feature in iron man 3. as the
title suggests
the 10 rings the terrorist organization
who kidnapped tony stark and iron man
will also figure prominently into the
on-screen origin of shang chi
who is arguably the finest unarmed
combatant in the marvel universe
destin daniel [ __ ] has been tapped to
direct with chinese canadian actor simul
liyu holding down the title role
also confirmed to be starring our
aquafina in an undisclosed role as well
as the legendary chinese actor tony
liang
as the mandarin himself another long
rumored project to finally be confirmed
at comic con in 2019 was the disney plus
series the falcon and the winter soldier
which will see anthony mackie and
sebastian stan reprising their roles of
steve rogers two best buddies
it seems that sam wilson may have a bit
of reconciling to do between his old
heroic identity and the new identity
bequeathed to him by rogers himself at
the conclusion of avengers in-game exact
plot details have so far been kept under
wraps but we do know one thing for sure
the six episode series will see the
return of zemo the man who goaded the
avengers into the titular conflict of
captain america civil war and he'll even
be sporting his distinctive purple mask
from the comics
the handmaid's tale director karis
goldwyn will helm
every episode with writing duties being
handled by empires malcolm spellman and
john wick's derrick colstadt
here's a project that should ring all
kinds of nostalgia bells for long time
marvel comic readers
what if is an alternate universe
anthology series which has run in
various formats since 1977
exploring how events may have unfolded
if crucial moments in the mainstream
marvel timeline had played out
differently
it allows readers to consider scenarios
both intriguing
and unthinkable and what it did for the
comics the disney plus animated series
what if
intends to do for the mcu like its comic
book counterpart
whatif will have an anthology format
with each episode tackling one specific
moment in the mcu timeline
disney's expanding the universe
featurette on disney plus
confirmed the premise of several of the
series episodes including what if peggy
carter had taken the super soldier serum
what if t'challa was star-lord
and what if captain america was a zombie
the marvel studios comic-con panel
revealed an impressive lineup of mcu
talent set to lend their voices
with many of the film's biggest stars
set to reprise their roles
they will be joined by jeffrey wright in
the central role of ua2 the watcher
whose job is to watch over the
multiverse and who will act as a sort of
host tying each episode together
at the panel wright teased the
practically limitless possibilities the
series might offer
we'll see where we take it we can take
it anywhere
given the fact that it kicked off a
universe of spider-man characters which
probably won't actually feature
spider-man the success of sony's venom
was a bit of a shock
anchored by tom hardy's completely
bonkers performance the film cleaned up
at the worldwide box office to the tune
of 855
million dollars making a sequel pretty
much obligatory
of course having learned a few tricks
from marvel studios
sony made sure to go ahead and set one
up in advance with a post-credits scene
featuring woody harrelson
as cletus cassidy the psychopathic
serial killer who will go on to become
carnage
the venom symbiote's terrifying
offspring one stumbling block the sequel
faced was the departure of venom
director ruben fleischer who had his
hands full with the long-awaited
follow-up to his 2009 classic zombieland
now motion capture legend andy circus
has stepped up to the helm
with original scribe kelly marcel
already drafting a screenplay and hardy
set to return
along with co-star michelle williams
plot details are sketchy right now
but one thing is certain just as cassidy
promised in that stinger there's gonna
be well
carnage indeed variety confirmed what
everyone expected in january 2019
that harrelson's homicidal symbiote will
be the movie's main villain
venom let there be carnage was expected
to hit theaters on october 2nd
2020 but was later moved to a summer
2021 release
among the first batch of marvel disney
plus series is loki which sees tom
hiddleston returning to portray the
beloved trickster once more
while our version of the character met a
grim end in the brutal opening sequence
of avengers infinity war the series will
follow the 2012 version of loki who
disappeared with the tesseract during
the bungled time heist in avengers
in-game according to the hollywood
reporter the series will follow loki as
he pops up throughout human history as
an unlikely
influencer on historical events the
project has scored a showrunner who
should know his way around this kind of
material too
michael waldron who has worked as a
writer on adult swims rick and morty and
will be credited as creator and
executive producer
in addition to writing the pilot
meanwhile kate herron will direct
joining heidelston will be fellow cast
members owen wilson
sophia dimartino google and batara and
richard e grant
all in undisclosed roles that said
wilson is taking on the role of a man
called mr mobius
while richard e grant is thought to be
playing an older alternate version of
loki himself
rounding out the first round of disney
plus limited series will be hawkeye
which will see jeremy renner reprise his
role as the legendary wisecracking
archer
during 2019 san diego comic-con marvel
debuted the series logo
as well as the confirmation of a
long-standing rumor that the series will
see the debut of
kate bishop the young protege who
eventually takes up the mantle of
hawkeye in the comics
the series is confirmed to take place
after the events of avengers in-game so
it'll likely see clint barton adjusting
to a world in which his beloved family
has returned from the snap and his
trusted ally natasha ramanov is no more
while no plot details were announced
renner did share one little tidbit with
the comic-con crap
which suggests that barton's mentorship
of bishop will be key to the series
narrative
renner joked i get to teach someone else
how to be a superhero without super
powers
what i get to do in the show ultimately
is shepherd an amazing
character to be ultimately probably a
better version of me
fans have been clamoring for kate
bishop's story to make its way to the
screen for some time but they'll have to
wait a bit longer to see it come to
fruition
hawkeye is scheduled to debut on disney
plus in the fall of 2021
in 2019 marvel studios opened their
comic-con panel with eternals
an interesting if lesser-known property
which should help anchor the cosmic side
of the mcu
the titular race of super-powered beings
were created eons ago by the celestials
in order to defend the earth from their
polar opposites the deviants
the eternals were the brainchild of the
great jack kirby who created the comic
in the mid 70s after his run on new gods
at dc
marvel head honcho kevin feige has
teased that eternal story may span
tens of thousands of years telling an
epic story of the kind we haven't yet
seen in the mcu and the movie which will
be directed by the writers chloe zao
has assembled a suitably epic cast
eternals will star richard madden as
icarus
a first generation eternal and leader of
the movie's team of heroes
alongside him will be angelina jolie as
thinner gimmichand as cersei
and barry kieren as the villainous
eternal druid
meanwhile kumar nanjiani will appear as
kingo
a samurai and bollywood movie star
lauren ridloff will play a
gender-swapped version of makari a
tinkerer and engineer
and bryan tyree henry is fastos a master
weapons maker who nevertheless prefers
not to fight
salma hayek will play ajak another
gender swap character while liam mchugh
features as the trickster sprite
it's a heck of a cast and although the
eternals may not be a-list marvel
characters there's a good chance this
will become one of the studio's biggest
properties eternals is due for release
on february
12 2021. for just over a month during
the summer of 2019
spider-man fans were left broken-hearted
at the news that talks between disney
and sony pictures had broken down
in their shared custody agreement over
spider-man had come to an end
but then in late september the news
broke that the two studios had finally
decided to play nice
a new deal was struck which will allow
marvel studios to co-produce at least
one more spider-man film
and also feature the character in an
additional as yet undisclosed marvel
studios picture
it's been speculated that marvel's third
spider-man movie will essentially be
used to write the wall crawler out of
the mcu
in preparation for a move to sony's own
spider-verse but the reality could be a
lot more complex
and a lot weirder when jk simmons
reprised his role as jay jonah jameson
from sam raimi's spider-man trilogy in
the end credits of spider-man far from
home
everyone suspected something strange was
afoot in the mcu
now things are set to get even odder as
marvel revealed in october 2020
that spider-man 3 would pull in yet
another character from a previous
unrelated spider film with the
announcement that jamie foxx would be
returning as elektro
his character from the amazing
spider-man 2. since then
the return of many classic villains and
alternate spider-man have been confirmed
while far from home teased at a
multiverse that ultimately turned out to
be a ruse perpetuated by mysterio
simmons and now fox's inclusion seem to
suggest the real deal is on the way
a fully fledged multiverse that brings
together all of the past iterations of
spider-man
we'll learn more about how marvel's
various spider-verses fit together when
spider-man 3 hits theaters on december
17
2021 given the fantastic character arc
that unraveled over his last several
appearances
speculation had been running high for
some time that thor would be the first
avenger to land himself
a fourth solo film
because that's what heroes do in july
2019
marvel finally confirmed this was the
case with thor ragnarok's taiko waititi
returning to direct
but that wasn't all marvel announced
hitting theaters on february 11
2022 thor love and thunder will see the
return of natalie portman's jane
foster who will follow her character's
recent comic book footsteps by picking
up mjolnir to become thor herself
tessa thompson will also return as
valkyrie and kevin feige has confirmed
that this time around
it will be made explicit that the
character is bisexual
a first for a major character in an mcu
film it has also been
all but confirmed that the guardians of
the galaxy will be making an appearance
in the movie and that the main villain
will be played by none other than dark
knight alumnus christian bale
with all that in mind it's hard not to
believe that marvel will be expecting
love and thunder to be one of their
biggest and most popular phase 4
releases
frankly who could argue otherwise the
sequel to 2016's dr strange has been in
development
since before that flick even hit
theaters and last year
marvel announced some new details about
the project namely that it would be
titled doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness that it would co-star
elizabeth olsen as wanda maximoff
and that it would be directly influenced
by the events of wand division
the marvel faithful were suitably
psyched but then disaster struck
in january 2020 it was announced that
the movie's director scott derrickson
had left the picture due to creative
differences with marvel studios
fortunately fans didn't have to despair
for long because marvel promptly reached
into its hat
and pulled out one heck of a rabbit
taking over the picture will be none
other than sam raimi
who not only gave us one of the greatest
horror comedies of all time but also
helped set the entire template for the
modern superhero genre with his
spider-man trilogy
the second film of that trilogy 2004
spider-man 2
is to this day widely considered to be
among the very best comic book movies
ever made and for the sheer insanity
promised by the strange sequels title
the director seems like an
absolutely perfect fit for the role
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness releases on march 25th
2022 after the tremendous success of
2018's black panther a sequel seemed
like a foregone conclusion
and sure enough in the fall of 2018 the
hollywood reporter reported that black
panther 2 was officially happening
with original writer director ryan
coogler returning to write and direct
the sequel
and celebrated star chadwick boseman
expected to reprise his role as king
t'challa
tragically however in august 2020
bozeman passed away following a four
year struggle with cancer
the news came as a shock to bozeman's
fans and colleagues alike
as the actor had kept his condition and
treatment quiet even as he continued to
work
following the news of bozeman's passing
marvel declined to speculate on the
future of the black panther franchise
choosing instead to grieve the
heartbreaking and shocking loss
of one of the world's brightest stars
while it's safe to assume black panther
2 is still happening
there's no knowing right now when that
will be or what form the story will take
while some has speculated that his
on-screen sister shuri may take up the
black panther mantle
as she does in the comics the pain of
bozeman's passing is still too fresh for
anyone to publicly commit to a direction
for the franchise
one thing that is certain however is
that whenever black panther 2
does make its way to the screen both the
story and its characters will find a
suitable way to honor their king
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one